Dr Lila hatch from Noah with the s,
uh,
the marine ecologist with Stellwagen Bank,
which is off the coast of Massachusetts.
And we have Katie more program director
at the International Fund for Animal
Welfare.
I'm a biologist by training.
I'm the director of the Animal Rescue
Program at the International Fund for
Animal Welfare, which is actually
headquartered on Cape Cod. Um, and
in relation to this,
um,
part of my job is to direct our marine
mammal rescue and research team, um,
which is based here on the Cape and
responds to strandings basically from a
Plymouth south to the Rhode Island
border. And, um, we have, uh,
the unique privilege of being in an area
where we have regular mass strandings
of marine mammals. Um,
usually, uh, pilot whales,
Whiteside of dolphins and
common dolphins on Cape Cod.
And it's one of the three top hotspots
globally for mass strandings. Um,
and what makes us a
little bit different than,
than some of these other places in, for
example, Madagascar in this case is that,
um,
mass strandings on kid caught up,
been happening for centuries and
you can go back into pilgrim logs.
And actually read about masterminding.
So we know that the events here predate
the industrialized ocean and predate a
lot of this noise.
And so they're considered
kind of a natural mass
stranding and we use them kind
of as a control group. Um, for
comparison to other groups. Um,
what has developed in is very different.
Um,
in terms of what we do now is part of
what we do in our response is actually to
test the hearing of the dolphins
that strand in our area.
I'm a technology we didn't have in
hand when the stranding happened in
Madagascar. And so that's, um,
kind of a new advantage we have to
getting some background data, uh,
in terms of mitigation. And we actually
use sound to our advantage in some cases,
um,
using acoustic deterrence to drive
potential groups of animals that will
potentially mass strand in our hot spot
areas like Wellfleet and other spots and
Cape Cod bay, and using
it to actually, um,
drive animals further off shore
and prevent them from stranding.
So in some respects we're using
sound to our advantage. Um,
but that's where I stand with it.
Um, I, uh, um,
have a variety of where a different
variety of different hats working for the
federal government on this issue. Um, um,
the National Oceanic and atmospheric
administration where I work, um, manages,
um,
a national marine sanctuary,
which is the vast majority
of Massachusetts Bay
right off the shore here.
And our mandate is to protect all the
resources of that site, which include,
um, uh, very rich populations of
fish and marine invertebrates.
All of us, many of which are acoustically
sensitive and active make, make sounds.
You sound very actively.
And the famous cod for which we call
Cape The Cape Cod is an incredibly
acoustically, um, uh,
active fish makes sounds when it spawns,
uses those sounds to organize
it's courtship behavior.
So this is a,
this is an issue that is way richer
than marine mammals and the whales.
Um, and, uh, so I work
on a research program,
developing a research program,
um,
to look at what the influence is of,
uh,
underwater noise that humans produce on
this wealth of species in the sanctuary
context here.
And then the majority of my time now
actually I spend trying to work on our
agencies, many, many
legal mandates for um,
improving protection for marine a marine
life and our mandates stretch from a
lot of the things you saw
references to a in some ways in, in,
in that we've done,
we've passed laws in the 70s that protect
marine mammal populations above other
populations. Um, and we, um, uh,
have particular mandates to protect
endangered species and then we have
additional mandates to um,
ensure the sustainable ability to
harvest fish and marine invertebrates in
fisheries. And all of those diverse
mandates are part of Noah's portfolio.
And um,
usually they include inability to
protect populations or understand the
influence of human stressors and
noise is a big part of that portfolio,
increasingly large part of that portfolio.
So I work on the agencies
development of a new,
a 10 year vision for how to get our
arms around the fact that noise is
increasing at this exponential rate.
The fact that it really does challenge
a lot of the legal mechanisms and his
scientific mechanisms,
we have to address it and to try to make
sure that over the next decade we're in
a better position to, to
address this issue. So that's,
that's sort of what my task is.
Oh,
and when you wanted us to talk a little
bit about mitigation, right? Mitigation,
um, uh, it is an incredibly rich topic.
I won't go on for a long time,
but I'll just sort of touch on.
You heard the influence of sound
talked about. Um, in fact, Katie,
you did a really nice job of in the film,
you know,
reminding people that there are,
um,
sometimes we make it into two categories,
but really it's a little richer than that,
but to at least two ways that
we consider noise influence. Um,
and one is an injury,
direct trauma to ears,
either temporary or permanent loss of
hearing or in really extreme cases,
um, uh, death to the actual animal
just due to trauma to the physical,
the animals physiology.
Um,
then there's all of these adversive
strong adversive behavioral responses that
can lead to mortality is which
you heard a lot of reference to.
That's not trauma to the,
it can include trauma to the ear.
If indeed the animal in
responding, um, goes through these,
these decompression Ben
scenarios or they're adversion
winds them up on a beach,
then you can have mortality.
Um,
so there's these extreme
behavioral responses and
then there's an enormous gray
zone of things that are way,
way more difficult to get on top of.
And that you may think of as associated
with a lot of different environmental
issues that we deal with,
which is sub lethal impacts,
things that don't kill the animal.
Um,
but that we get concerned about happening
to them repeatedly in their lifetime
or happening to them chronically
in their lifetime. So mitigations,
there's a suite of mitigations that
we've gotten better and better at, um,
to address those lethal conditions,
especially for marine mammals.
Mechanisms for first off,
trying to reduce the co-occurrence
of animals, doing something,
anything actually anything at that close
proximity that will lead to any kind of
lethal interaction.
Um,
and that includes ramping up a source
more slowly and some conditions that's
effective in some did conditions.
It's not the most effective
thing is to reduce,
to use everything we can to
understand where animals are.
It's not an easy, easy task. And to, um,
have the activity described and in such
a way that they're not going to do it in
that space and in that time.
So restrict activities in,
in time and space to reduce their
co-occurrence with animals. That's the,
that's what in the prime mitigation
techniques associated with these acute
effects.
Um,
and it also starts to get out of some of
these additional sub lethal influences
of,
you know,
an animal may not have such an adversive
reaction that it winds up on the beach,
but it may have its feeding disrupted
and you may not worry about that if it
happens once.
But if it's in a location where there's
a lot of activity that's disruptive and
it's during a really important
biological activity, um, like,
um, this is a really Kunsthalle a lot
of marine mammal populations have very
constricted feeding times where
they're focused on, um, uh,
patches of prey that are in that
space and time and need to be, um,
they need to be efficiently Eaton.
And if they're getting disturbed,
there's a caloric effect on, you know,
just reducing the fitness of that animal,
reducing their ability to get the
calories they need. It's a very odd,
if you think about what a whale is,
it's an extremely odd
evolutionary phenomenon to
have the largest animals in the
world dependent on eating
a gigantic amount of the
smallest amount of animals in
the world.
And that's,
that was all built at the whole thing
works because of the relative predict,
uh,
predictiveness of an animal.
Being able to find those concentrations
and being able to take them in quickly.
And so if you mess up their
ability for them to, um, uh,
use that header heterogeneously
distributed resource the way they have to,
they don't have a lot of access to
another evolutionary mechanism to make up
that bad amount of calories.
So these are these sub lethal sweet and
that doesn't even get to the thing that
I actually concentrate
on the most and that I'm,
the reason that in the film
I concentrated on shipping,
which is that hum in the background and
the hum in the background is something
we're really just starting
to understand for humans.
So you can imagine why it's a difficult
thing to get regulations to understand
for marine critters,
which is if it's simply a
louder in the background,
what are all the different kinds of
signals that animals are dependent on
hearing that they now lose access to.
And we're so focused on whales as
communicators between each other and their
signals.
So there's,
the first thing we think about is the
loss of the ability to hear each other.
And that's what we're talking about in
the film in terms of right whales being
able to hear each other calling,
what are the ramifications of that?
But actually what we know from
terrestrial wildlife and birds,
all these other critters is that,
um,
they're using all kinds of sounds and
the natural environment to detect, um,
where's a good place to settle,
um,
to hear echoes over very large areas of
space that tell them something about,
um, the, the, the conditions of the,
the bottom that will tell them about
the predictability of food resources.
Definitely the ability to hear predators,
the ability to detect,
pray and all of these,
this is a really, you know,
the sound is a really ecologically
rich medium underwater.
And being able to detect those
cues has been really critical.
Trying to figure out how to mitigate
that gets to working on quiet or
technologies,
you know,
working at the scale that's relevant
to chronic influence of noise and the
buildup of these industries.
And so we work, um, uh,
we've been working a lot at the
international maritime organization,
which is a part of the UN,
which regulates worldwide commercial
shipping and got them to pass at the first
voluntary guidelines for
quiet and commercial vessels,
things that come or that the countries
that are party to the UN and that are
party to this.
Um,
these guidelines can begin to
figure out ways to put in place.
And that's one of the first ways you
bring an environmental stressor issue into
that,
that global business.
And we're working on those same types of
issues with air gun industry, you know,
with the oil and gas industry and with
the possibility of bringing vibroseis
into commercial, a widespread commercial
use. And so these are, those are the,
some of the things we have to
get at for chronic influence.
So was anybody designing more efficient,
quieter ship propellers
for the commercial traffic?
Uh, yes. I mean that the efficiency of a,
of a commercial propeller has something
that the shipping industry in a lot of
our meetings has said we'd,
you know, we've been working
on this for a long time.
It's not like we haven't been trying
to build commercial propellers,
but the pressures on the industry now
are greater than they have ever been.
Um, because, um,
the sh the global shipping industry
has to come into compliance for carbon
missions at a level that
they never have had to. Um,
and within the next five
to 10 years spectrum,
they have different milestones they have
to reach. That's the biggest design,
um, of design pressure
that's been on the, uh,
on new builds for 50 years,
other than maybe twin
hulled to reduce, um, uh,
issues with ballast and
an end. Um, um, uh, uh,
exotic, uh, you know, the
introduction of invasive species.
That was another huge design moment for
shipping. So the question now for us,
it's going to be how much of a noise gain
do we get from that pressure that this
greening moment in, um,
carbon emission design.
And that's been the biggest
pressure on what's a model basins,
which is where conglomerates
of shipping mostly in Korea,
Japan, I'm a little, you know the
a relatively large one that we,
that was spoken about a little
bit in Germany, but there are,
that's where most of that design
work has been and it's usually on the
combination of the hall and the propeller
and then there it always has to do
with operations, so it's this, it's
just this triple linked thing. It's,
it's the propeller design linked to
how the hall is built in, in, in,
in combination with a propeller design
and then the third component of is it
actually going to be used to the
design specs that will result in the
efficiencies that that it was built
for.
But I thought the issue
with propeller design,
you've got the efficiency and this quiet
at the same time as the cavitation.
That's the problem that costs us a noise
and causes a loss of efficiency of the
propeller.
It's interesting,
I have to tell you that there would be
other voices up here who would be from
the industry who will be saying
it's nowhere near that simple.
There's whole sectors of shipping
and PR and propeller use. Um,
they have to do with which engine is where
power is paired with which propeller.
Um,
that would say that it's not a
direct linear relationship and um,
that it has to do with a variable.
There's a kind of propeller called
variable speed propellors that are in some
kind of use and you know, so, uh, it,
it's just not a completely direct
relationship. Others say that.
Overarchingly and I think that's,
some of the statements that
are in the film I think are,
they're hard won over several conferences
to get to a place where we feel
comfortable saying, yeah, but there's a
big wind there that's still potential for,
um, that said and understanding how to
match that with where we want to be.
Um, you know, ships have
an 40 to 50 year lifetime.
So we have to figure out how to deal with
existing vessels and retrofits are not
going to be possible at the design level.
And so we're going to have to
build better ships. You absolutely.
And there's that.
That build is probably going
to be pressured not only
by noise if we're lucky,
but by the sort of green ship of tomorrow
holistic design package that gets at
the regulatory pressures that
are coming down the pike.
And then we have to figure out how to
operate the ships we have now is mostly
what it's going to be to get
their noise profile down.
Let me ask you about the other two main
sources that the film talked about.
Uh, one is oil and gas
exploration. So what is the,
what kind of progress,
if any, is there in, uh,
oil companies and gas companies adopting,
uh,
these lower frequency or less
invasive, um, exploration technologies,
number one,
and number two is the navy and sonar.
I would imagine that,
um,
where the navy is going to be going
in the future with sonar and related
technologies is probably
highly classified. Uh,
but do you have any information on or
have you been heard anything from the navy
or from other countries, navies about, um,
the possibility of adopting technologies
in the future that are less damaging
in the oil and gas community?
There had been sectors, um,
uh, well the major, the
major oil and gas, um,
worldwide companies had been investing,
had been the prime investors since
the 70s in some of these alternative
technologies like marine vibroseis.
So they're not a new phenomenon. Um,
there,
um,
and that investment has indeed
been from the industry. Um,
the implementation of that is
this constant dance between,
um, it takes millions of dollars to outfit
a geological and geophysical surveying
vessel.
And the fleet that's out
there now therefore has an
enormous amount invested in
the current technology and the areas
of air guns that are being used. Um,
so figuring out, um, and the, the,
the bureau of Ocean Energy Management,
which a part of the,
uh, department of the interior
and that directly regulates, um,
geophysical exploration. And then
subsequent oil and gas development. Um,
Noah works in very close
partnership with, um, that bureau.
Um,
our job is usually to help that bureau.
It has its own mandates to figure out
environmental oversight and has its own
mechanisms by which it could incentivize
the development of those technologies.
And we don't have that direct line.
And Noah,
our job is to evaluate
the impacts and to um,
authorize,
um,
a level of impact if we can find it
to be negligible on some populations.
So that assessment,
we have a lot co-invested
in the assessment realm
and we absolutely have been
part of governmental. Uh, there's a,
an industry I'd called the joint industry,
uh,
Prom Joint Mr program that has developed
an entire marine vibroseis s three
stage, heavily invested
by Exxon Shell, BP,
all of the companies program to,
to try to see if they can get to,
um,
vibroseis in use in context and
really do a proof of concept.
All the way from the build.
So they have three companies who went
in to show them that they had these
mechanisms and they're taking them through
the various stages of real industrial
development.
What I hear from industry is that as
there's never going to be a complete
replacement, but that's the way
they talk about it right now. Um,
but that there will be conditions under
which we could see a lot more use of
vibroseis.
So I think we're definitely in a slower,
slower or in a different place.
We're in a, uh, an um, uh, we're,
we're walking forward. Um, and you
know, sometimes it's a little bit,
two steps forward,
three steps back because the oil and gas
industry goes through its own economic
stages in which it's more progressive
and feels like it has more resources to
fund the next stage. And this is not
that time, oil and gas industry. So,
you know, these things
go in ebbs and flows. Um,
the u s navy, um, I'm, uh,
I'm not as privy to what
a future technology or
replacement would be for sonar.
And, um, that's not something I can
speak to. Um, but there has been,
um,
a lot of work,
very close work between Noaa and the
navy to develop mitigation programs over
time and space. And, um, I think
I'll leave it there for now.
I can speak just to the last
little bit with the navy.
And it is definitely true that there's a,
um,
there's a lot more focus on the navy
to really comply with standards.
They have to have their permits in
order now and they have to have, um,
impact statements ready to go
and have evaluated the impact.
And in that there are mitigation measures
built in when they're doing exercises.
The other piece of that is,
um,
Noah is the,
the permitting agency for all of the
stranding that works around the United
States.
And so I'm working through Noah and
in conjunction with the navy and being
prepared with protocols and knowing when
exercises might be going on in certain
areas so that we can be prepared to,
um,
to deal with the strandings but also to
document what might be happening and it
can trigger a shutdown of what they're
doing depending on what comes up.
So at least there's a
lot more communication,
which I think is a huge
step forward as well. Um,
I've been an environmentally concerned
citizens since I was this high and I
had no idea about the issues with sonic
pollution in the sea.
So I think maybe the most important
way the public can affect the outcomes
positively for the marine mammals and
other animals is to just know about it.
So, uh, how can we help
promote this message?
And once it is more,
um,
I guess known about what can
the public do to affect this?
It's really great
questions. Um, and uh, it's,
it's interesting, you know, the, um,
before this movie was made and this
movie is not going to obviously save,
save the world, right? It's
not going to be the end of the,
and really an important need
for outreach, but it has, um,
promoted a lot more dialogue. You
know, we, just to give an example,
we recently put out a document that was
really Noah kind of talking to itself
about how to do this work better.
So we decided not to really
do a press release about it,
but we really did want the
public to know we were doing it.
We got over a hundred thousand comments
back on the document and it was covered
on, you know, in the front second
page of the Washington Post.
So that would not have happened without
this movie happening over this past
year. And without a lot of
concurrent, um, outreach perspectives.
I actually am somebody who
has worked on Naval Sonar, um,
uh, assessment issues in,
in, in, uh, some past phases.
And I've been concerned with the
disproportionate attention to enable sonar
relative to a lot of other sources of
underwater noise that I feel are having
really strong effects and that we are
less prepared and have less of a history
with developing mitigation
and developing dialogues with,
with specific industries. So I've, um,
I that has, that has been the largest, uh,
outreach. Um, and the largest messaging,
the most pervasive outreach and messaging
around ocean noise issues has been
around a court cases
and navy sonar. And, um,
I have been pleased to see that even
some of the same groups that had been
carrying that message for so long are
part of now making a film that is saying
this is actually not an
issue about navy sonar.
It's much more holistic than that.
It's much more deeply ingrained in the
way that animals use this environment and
the, you know, many sources of sound
that can contribute to it. So it,
it's been a combination to me of figuring
out how to tell a a story about sub
lethal impacts under of
any nature is tricky.
Having worked with CBS News and
having them come to me and say,
but the shipping noise thing isn't
it killing them? And you, you know,
you know that he really wants you to
say yes because that's the story and the
answer is no, it's making it
really hard to be out there,
but you sure it's not killing them.
Yep. I think it's, you know, so again,
we have to tell a complicated story
and, um, and we have to keep telling it.
Um, I think what we've said
to people is that they're,
so at Noah where we have a lot of
different outreach perspectives.
We have 14 sites that were um,
our,
our version of national parks off shore,
um,
that are these national
marine sanctuaries. There are
good storytelling media. Um,
and we have very large local
constituencies that are
often very engaged in these
places off shore that are
there. And Marian, you know,
your and our national marine sanctuaries.
Um,
we've started to increasingly engaged
them and telling the ocean noise story
where you started to increasingly engage
them and putting recorders there and
having live streaming of sound from these
places so that people can start to get
at this sensory medium that is this place.
And we're often asked the
question what can I do? And um,
it is a tricky one. It is. I
think being educated about it,
understanding it as part of the balancing
act we do surrounding how we move
goods around surrounding. And how
you, how you as a purchaser, um,
can consider this as part of global
transiting of stuff that yeah, I'm,
that we all buy that is something
that we've talked about. Um,
and um,
other than that is part of very large
decisions about energy offshore energy
development that we can
do, um, smartly we can,
that we can do in, in the, uh,
with pressures to do it very intelligently
and thinking a lot about marine life.
Um,
I think that those are the ways that we,
the messages that we've started to
develop the most and make them place based
where people can start to
attach themselves to them
because people are often
very attached to particular ocean
more than they are the ocean.
I think from a nonprofit perspective,
we do,
part of what we do with all of the
different issues that we face is trying to
get the public aware of it and giving
out the right information and making sure
good science is out there to inform
really good policy development.
Um,
I had a really interesting conversation
last night with someone who was talking
about the fact that the,
the size testing that was going on in
Madagascar prior to that stranding was a
multibeam echo sounder, which is kind of
like what you'd see on anybody's boat.
I mean it was industrial sized one,
but it was like what you'd use as a fish
finder or depth finder on your personal
watercraft.
So when you start thinking
about the number of vessels
that are on the water and
how many people have these as
part of what's out there now,
granted that's a very small
scale and not very strong. Um,
but I think an awareness of, of
everything we're doing, you think back to,
you know,
seventies and eighties and the,
the ads about not littering
and things like that,
that was kind of this
revolutionary movement.
It's a similar kind of thing and
awareness of the impact that we have as
individuals. And then I think
looking for those opportunities,
we get to the point,
you know,
certainly at a national level and
looking at legislation that can help, um,
regulate this in a meaningful way that,
that supports the kind of
work we all have to do.
Whether it's national security
or having the goods that we need,
but also protects the
environment. Um, you know,
and then looking at it and
finding ways to support that.
But also we have to
think on a global scale.
And that's where it gets really difficult
for me is processing noise on a global
scale.
So, um, I had, uh,
written professor Christopher Clark with
a question and he actually wrote back
during the movie.
So I just read his response,
but I want to ask you to the
same question and first style.
I'll read his response.
I wondered about the role of citizen
science and he wrote for Marine Acoustics,
we're still in the embryonic stage.
The number of people recording in the,
in the ocean has increased dramatically.
And the challenge is not data collection
so much as it is data processing.
For example,
the bioacoustics research lab norm
routinely collects the equivalent of
somewhere around 120 280 years of
raw acoustic data every 12 months.
And we have to search through all of
those using various auto detection
algorithms, most recently on
high performance computers.
And there's lots of tech,
no discussions that
could follow on this one.
So I wish he were here to tell us
more about that. Um, but he says it's,
it's like where's Waldo and needles
in haystacks within haystacks.
Ah, but I wonder what a, you two
could say, not just in acoustics,
but in general about the role of
citizen science in any of these.
Hmm, sure. Um,
vital in many respects would
be my answer to that. Um,
we at the international front in front,
I'm a welfare and most stranding networks
around the country and around the
globe for that matter,
rely on volunteers.
So the general public to come in and
it's not just a matter of come in,
pick up a dolphin,
help us get it back in the water.
It's come in and help us collect data,
help us pull it together.
And trying to utilize,
a lot of times we have people that have
retired from incredible careers that
have this skill set that
they can bring to us, um,
and really give us some additional
benefit that we wouldn't necessarily have
expected. I think that the other,
the other piece of citizen science,
you can see there's different
programs around the world.
I know of one in Australia where
they're looking at a lot of oil and gas
exploration and development
and there's not that,
some really remote places along the
coastline and they actually set up a great
program. I'm part of it was through
Duke University in getting, um,
boaters and coastal folks to report
sightings and take photographs.
I had this great app that they had and
you could take a picture and send it in.
And so they were tracking,
um,
presence and absence of different
species of marine mammals,
the coast to try and develop a data
set that didn't really exist. Um,
and it's a much less
expensive way to do that.
Then trying to get a survey vessel out
there with paid observers and all the
things that you need to do that
which still needs to be done.
But this gives that, um, an added
layer of data they can come into it.
So I think there's a huge role
and I think as we go forward,
a more informed population gives us the
opportunity to engage more people with
an interest to do more of that work.
No, I think I, uh, I think
that covers a lot. I mean,
the other citizen science programs I was
thinking of were very similar in terms
of integrating, um,
integrating citing information.
Then those have been powerful.
And you, the, the base,
the basis of mitigation development
is knowing where animals are.
And it's a huge, huge,
huge task to describe,
well how animals use the environment in
a way that you can then prevent overlap.
And it's the most powerful way
we have of reducing influence.
So getting citizens engaged in that
effort is, is really, um, has it,
has a lot of potential.
Okay.
And I personally also have a more
Katie more oriented question,
which is that I'm very curious about
the incidence response that you do.
Like how do you hear about something?
How do you organize a response?
What's it like to go there?
What is the follow up?
Well, local responses
easy comparatively. Um,
thankfully,
um,
folks on Cape Cod and in the areas that
we respond a really keenly aware of
what's supposed to be happening in the
water in front of their house or on the
beach in front of the house
and what's out of the ordinary.
And so we get a lot of reports,
early morning beach walkers,
things like that of when a seal or a
dolphin or whale might be either swimming
close to shore,
out of habitat or up on the beach stranded
when it comes to responding outside
of our normal like response area here on
the Cape, it's a lot more challenging.
When we got the call from Madagascar,
it just so happened that this stranding
took place during a meeting of the
international whaling commission so big.
So basically every big whale biologist
on the planet was concentrated in
Santiago, Chile, and they sent out a
plea for help do a handful of folks.
And um,
within 20 hours we were
on a plane on our way.
We met our colleagues that we had never
met before on an Air France flight going
from Paris into Madagascar. And, um,
it's a really difficult, difficult thing
to do to respond in real time globally.
Um, you know, the animals that we see,
the less time they spend out of the water,
the better when you're talking about
a dolphin or a whale. And so our,
one of the keys to our success here on
the Cape is how fast we can get there and
how quickly our local volunteers that
are trained can get there before us if
it's in their backyard.
Um,
when I first started out
with mass stranded animals,
if we got to them and they were
still alive when we got there,
they had about a 14 chance of surviving.
Um,
and now we're upwards of 80%. Um,
just because of the techniques.
We have lots of experience volunteers,
we've learned a lot over the years in
terms of how to treat the animals, um,
both from supportive care and medically.
Um,
we don't have that advantage when we're
talking about flying around the world
and taking two days to get there.
So we're limited in the kinds of responses
we can do. But basically we'll get,
there will be a call out from,
you know,
it can be another nonprofit or
a government looking for help.
I think one of the best things that we
have going for us is how small the world
has become because of the way we can
easily communicate with one another.
So information is shared so rapidly that
they can call out for help and you can
get folks, um, on the road
or at least informing.
We share a lot of information online
and over the phone to try and get teams
locally, um, able to respond in.
One of our projects we're working on
now actually with Noaa and the Marine
Mammal Center in Sausalito is, um, an
international stranding response tool kit.
So basically it would be all the
resources you need from what,
what,
figuring out what legislation you have
in your country to what permits you need,
who your partner should be, how do you get
funded, how do you recruit a volunteer,
how do you get trained, um, and what are
all the protocols you need from a to z.
Um, and the goal would be to have, um,
folks around the globe that we know are
kind of already qualified in all of this.
They're already helping us develop it
internationally and then have them be the
initial trainers.
But the goal is to train the trainers.
So we're training people on the ground,
then develop networks in their areas
and share what they know with their
neighbors.
So would just continued to grow on its
own and be this free resource that would
help kind of solve some of these emergent
problems or you have to be really,
really quick and response. So that's,
I think the longterm solution is there.
Thank you for, um, uh, providing
the opportunity costs for,
for showing the film
here and, um, for, uh,
becoming informed about this
issue. And, um, I could make a,
um, uh, uh, give a shout out to, um,
some of the things that are
happening from Noah this summer. Um,
we are,
um,
working on releasing are a final copy of
this 10 year vision for how the agency
is, um, uh, looking to improve
the way we address ocean noise.
And that's at a website called set
sound.noaa.gov and there's a lot of
information there about what we do and um,
the draft that we put out that got
a lot of public comment and um,
feel free to reach out to us and there's
our information is all in that site.
I would say thank you as well.
This was a great chance to come and
share a little bit of what we do. Um,
and I guess my request would be share
what you've learned and share your
enthusiasm. I think that
goes a long way. Um,
if you're really interested in marine
mammals and doing some volunteer work and
doing an aquarium has a fantastic
stranding response program as well,
and sea turtles as well for them. Um,
and we do down on the Cape as well.
So everybody's always looking for a
volunteer. So if you're willing and able
[inaudible].